cbs news has learned that the chief of
staff to former vice president mike
pence warned the secret service that
then president donald trump would
publicly turn against pence and that it
could pose a security threat to him marc
short issued the warning on the day
before the capitol insurrection it's
something he is likely to be asked about
when he testifies publicly before the
january 6th committee meanwhile the
department of justice revealed that it
will not prosecute trump's former chief
of staff mark meadows and adviser dan
scavino both of whom refused to
cooperate with the committee but another
former trump administration official did
find himself in the sites of prosecutors
friday jeff pigas has that story
former top trump aide peter navarro was
arrested yesterday at reagan national
airport as he waited to board a flight
instead of calling me and said hey we
need you down at court
we've got a warrant for you we're glad
we come what did they do they
intercepted me getting on the plane and
then they put me in handcuffs
bringing here they put me in leg irons
appearing in federal court navarro
complained about how he was apprehended
calling it despicable prosecutors may
have been concerned that he was trying
to flee alleging in the indictment that
at each and every turn the former
adviser to president trump is all but
ignored a lawful subpoena to appear
before the january 6th committee
anxious to speak with him about his
efforts to overturn the election
their clear mission is to prevent donald
john trump from running the president in
2024. the indictment includes two counts
of contempt of congress for refusing to
appear before the committee and failing
to provide information on the so-called
green bay sweep what navarro referred to
in his book as the last best chance to
snatch a stolen election from the
democrats jaws of deceit the election's
over the voting is over but the outcome
is not
the plan allegedly developed with former
white house adviser steve bannon also
indicted on contempt of congress charges
sought to stop former vice president
mike pence from certifying the 2020
presidential election in the meantime
peter navarro will be here back in court
on june 17th
cbs saturday morning jeff begay is in
washington